We've already seen a lot of logarithms used in this lesson and we're only going
to keep using them more. So I think it's time that you learn how to use
mathquill to write logs in a pretty way. Now they should be pretty similar to
some other functions you've seen written in mathquill. And of course you'll get
plenty of practice using this. Let's say for example that I want to write log
base 4 of x. Well, in mathquill here is what I would type in, \ log, then the
spacebar, then to get down into this subscript space where the four is written,
need to press Shift and then hold it down while you type the Minus sign key.
That's what's going to shift you down here. Then you can write a little four
just to the bottom right of the log. To get out of the space and get back to
where we're going to write the input for the log press the Arrow key to the
right. You could also press Tab instead then take your input which in this case
is x. Now since you've seen one example I think it would make sense for you to
try one yourself. How would you type log base 3 of x plus 4 in mathquill. In
the box that appears down here. Try it out. You should be able to tell based on
how it looks, whether or not it's going to be right. You could also use the box
down here to try out writing some other log expressions, anything you can think
of.